[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain an australian sci-fi drama
television series called the unlisted
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
in the opening scene a bunch of middle
school students are running down an
empty alleyway two adults follow them
closely but lose them around a subway
track the children hide behind a wall
alone and scared somewhere else in
australia lives a family of six named
the sharma family the sharma twins drew
and cal are identical but have entirely
different personalities they are usually
separated as the brother who wears
glasses and the one who doesn't one
morning the elder brother drew dreams of
someone drilling his teeth and wakes up
scared his twin laughs making fun of
drew's unreasonable fear of dentists the
family is busy preparing for the diwali
celebration their grandmother prepares
them breakfast before assigning them
individual tasks to be done by the end
of the day recently drew hacked into his
school's database to see his test
results early this got him into a lot of
trouble but his parents allow him to use
his computer after a week-long
restriction cal huffs knowing that drew
has been using his phone as usual for
the past week in the following scene
they go to school and meet a mutual
friend chloe as they talk their entire
class has called for a compulsory dental
checkup assigned by the global child
initiative program a classmate named tim
runs away claiming that his parents do
not approve of the checkup drew who
dreads the idea of dental checkups asks
cal to take his place cal wears drew's
glasses and goes in a second time the
doctors do not suspect him and perform
the same procedure on him twice
in class their teacher mr park surprises
them with a test which is also set by
the global child initiative program a
representative of the said program miss
biggs comes to the class as the
invigilator a few minutes into the test
the students freeze out of the blue drew
is the only normal one in the class and
is confused out of his mind miss biggs
however seems to know what's going on
she collects the report about the
condition of the children and doesn't
notice that drew is still moving some
seconds later they return to their
normal selves and continue the test as
if nothing happened after the class drew
tries asking cal why he froze but cal
doesn't know what he is talking about
this is followed by a series of strange
incidents like cal cycling really fast
without realizing and breaking a glass
of ghee with his bare hands drew
repeatedly tries telling him something
is off but cal thinks he is being
dramatic later the brothers are outside
a store when tim comes running to them
he is the same guy who refused the
dental checkup that day he tells them to
not trust anyone and be careful before
running away the twins notice a black
van following tim and decide to pursue
them both but they cannot keep up with
the car and eventually lose them in the
evening is the diwali celebration but
the guys are too occupied to enjoy the
festival they call tim's parents who are
just as worried suddenly a group of men
kidnaps the couple before ending the
call the brothers think of calling the
police but remember that tim asked them
to not trust anyone they also do not
want to tell their parents because that
would put them at risk of being
kidnapped then we see the students who
we saw in the opening scene they are
also running away from the agents of the
program the agents monitor the entire
city's cctv footage to look for the kids
the next day at school the twins class
is made to take a physical test in it
the students show exceptional athletic
abilities that are too advanced for
their age except for drew who struggles
to keep up with his classmates miss
biggs notices this and calls him to the
sickbay for a test drew immediately
changes places with kyle and makes him
go with the teacher miss biggs takes a
look at his gums with the excuse of
checking his throat cal realizes that
during the dental checkup they must have
been planted with some kind of bug that
is causing him and the others to act
weird but since drew skipped the test he
remained normal
these brothers are slow on the uptake i
figured that out like three paragraphs
ago the brothers secretly use their
teacher's computer and find a database
full of the students records it contains
everything about the kids including
their live location since cal has two
implants on either side of his jaw the
information about him gathered by the
implant is also used as druze meanwhile
tim is labeled as the unlisted one
because he never went through the
process somewhere else the other group
running from the organization finds a
working walkie-talkie in the trash bin
since they cannot communicate through
their phones they decide to use the
device at home the brothers also get
themselves radio phones to communicate
they research the global child
initiative program and find out an
organization named the infinity group is
behind the idea to check the phone's
range cal goes outside and sees a
vehicle in front of tim's house the
agents see him and chase him down the
road but cal manages to escape as he and
drew talk on the phone they pick up the
other group's frequency and hear their
voice they try to communicate with the
group and gain their trust by telling
them how they knew about the program the
leader of the other group rose calls
them to meet the next day at a hill rose
and her group steal lunch boxes from
people at the park they know they cannot
go on for long in such conditions and
are desperate for outside help in
contrast the sharma boys are being fed
in abundance by their grandmother at
school they play kabadi but are placed
on two different teams because of cal's
newfound strength he easily wrestles the
other team but this also makes the
agents suspicious of him drew asks him
to lose the next round so they won't be
caught cal reluctantly does as told but
is enraged because of the loss a
teacher's pet named regan records him
kicking a bin and making it fly a few
yards away she decides to show it to
miss biggs later after school the
brothers bribe their elder sister to
cover for them while they go to meet
rose and her friends when they finally
reach the location they find no one
around all of a sudden someone puts bags
over their heads in an attempt to kidnap
them but against cal strength they are
proven weak it turns out they are not
the agents but rose and her friends they
wanted to abduct the guys to make sure
they are not with the rival group during
the struggle rose's friend jacob gets
hurt he and cal stay at the park to make
sure the other group isn't bluffing
while the others go to the hideout where
drew tells them everything the group
reveals that they also didn't get the
dental implants because of some
disturbance which is why they are
unlisted and are on the agent's hit list
they do not know what exactly the motive
of the program is but they are sure some
powerful people are trying to control
the youngsters drew tells them about tim
and his parents who were abducted which
only makes the group feel worse drew
senses their worry and assures them that
their parents are all right even though
he is unsure himself back in the park
jacob and cal share samosas and bond
over their favorite sports team jacob is
still in a lot of pain because of his
leg injury but feels at peace for the
first time since all of this started
drew and rose arrive an hour later and
the group goes their separate ways the
next day in class the teacher's pet
regan is made the monitor and is tasked
to tell the agents about any suspicious
activity happening at school she shows
miss biggs the video of cal kicking the
bin but instead of being mad miss biggs
is happy about the strength that he has
gained the students are made to take yet
another physical test but this time they
are controlled using the dental implants
miss biggs makes them walk and turn in a
certain way to check their coordination
drew follows the others and manages to
hide the fact that he is not being
controlled suddenly everything goes back
to normal and the ones who were
controlled do not remember anything on
their way back home the twins are
approached by rose they quickly rush to
the hideout to see that jacob's injury
has gotten worse he has a fever because
of the infection that will surely get
worse if not treated immediately to help
him drew and cal go to their aunt maya's
clinic they plan to stall her and steal
some antibiotics but she catches on to
their strange behavior when she calls
them out for it they have no choice but
to ask her for help still they only tell
her about the injured kid not about the
infinity group the three of them come to
the hideout to be attacked by rose and
the others they think the twins betrayed
them but the boys quickly explained the
situation maya is shocked to see the
condition the kids are living in she
takes care of jacob's injury first
before asking the kids what is going on
they assure her they are doing the right
thing but refuse to tell her what it is
about when the guys return home they are
worried about their aunt they think her
life is at risk because she helped them
but then they notice her talking to the
infinity group's agents and getting into
their car the guys suspect she is one of
them but are sure she wouldn't put her
nephew's lives in danger in the
following scene we see some men entering
the hideout that rose and the group are
in they quickly pack their things and
rush outside before being caught drew
doesn't get a hold of them through the
walkie-talkie and goes to see if they
are all right meanwhile cal goes to
school as usual drew secretly enters the
hideout and sees killed insects on the
floor however the group is nowhere to be
seen the construction workers spot him
and chase him away he figures that the
group is probably safe and had to hide
because of the workers at school three
agents from the infinity group stay in
the classroom throughout the lecture but
something more strange happens when tim
returns to school as if nothing ever
happened the guys try talking to him
during recess but he dismisses the
conversation after school drew returns
home and wants cal to join because the
agents might notice the implant's
location and drew's location are
different but cal decides to stay at
school for football practice during
warm-up the coach asks cal to call tim
cal runs to his home and calls him
outside however tim seems to not know
anything about the practice he claims
that his parents are on a business trip
so he has to stay home before cal can
ask him what is wrong an agent calls him
from inside the house she comes to the
window and scans cal asking where his
brother is cal panics and pretends to
call drew before running away but the
interaction makes an impression on the
agent cal goes home and tells drew
everything that happened they go to the
hideout again to check if rose and the
group have returned thankfully they find
the group outside it turns out they were
in a hidden room that they found inside
the sewage system they go to the said
room that looks like it was used by
someone in the past it is not the ideal
living environment but is better than
the previous arrangement a while later
the twins return home cal suddenly stops
and his eyes glow blue it is clear that
he is being controlled but drew doesn't
notice it they finally come back home
and enjoy dinner with their family maya
is also there and is worried about the
kids in the last scene she reveals that
she has been hired by the infinity group
as a medical officer the twins look at
each other in confusion unsure if they
can trust her anymore subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching